joining us right now from the worldwide
leader in sports I'm kind of dating
myself I always said this to shefter -
he's like the EF Hutton of Sports
information when people when they talk
people listen
he's Adrienne Roche and rouse give ESPN
how are you watch I'm well rich hope
hope you are - yeah we are we're not
gonna would we're all happy and healthy
and safe and I guess I'll you know I'll
start with the macro question here I
read your latest piece on espn.com it's
remarkable your reporting as always as
spot-on
with detail what is what are what are
the conversations right now in in the
NBA front office is Adam Silver having
right now here on may the first 2020
about this upcoming season best you can
tell well thanks for Jack
the conversations are so wide-ranging
there's so many layers to trying to play
again this season but also playing again
this season and context with what next
season looks like and the following
season because if you push back the
start of next season you know you're
essentially probably pushing back the
start of the following season and so
what kind of calendar do you want to get
in is that a one year thing if if they
don't play this year might they still
move next year's star back anyway to buy
more time to be able to get fans and
arenas buy more time in a lot of areas
and if they play this season how do they
play where do they play
do they just go right to the playoffs do
they just do they have some regular
season left or do they do a play in
tournament there's so many scenarios and
contingencies and many of them rich
think really are built around how many
days they have to work with and
initially they had hoped in a resumed
season they had hoped to have it wrapped
up by especially Labor Day weekend start
a football season that first weekend in
September and as time has gone on you
know they're they're more open or
they're open to pushing it further if
they need to if that means they can get
the playoffs finished and they want to
be able to crown a champion that's
important to them and but they've also
got to have a champion that comes out of
a representative process playoffs it's
got a it's got to have legitimacy to it
and and so that's the fine line because
you're going to have to compromise in
lots of ways no fans may be sure to
playoff series maybe you don't have a
best-of-seven maybe you do that there's
so many different and I think what
they're trying to do is you know I had a
quote in the story from an executive in
the league I was talking about Adams
challenge and just how difficult it is
to lead in a crisis by consensus and and
I think there's consensus that everybody
wants to play and that's important for
the league to play even for even though
for some individual teams or you know
who are not going to be in the playoffs
I mean Steve Kerr said the other day
yeah you know we're operating as if
we're done and there really isn't any
motivation for them to want to play a
few more games or do a mini camp and
then start play a few regular-season
games and be done but it's important for
the league that they resume and
certainly financially there's benefits
to playing for some teams there's
benefits to getting the players money
back with cancelled games and so lots of
agendas and a commissioner right now
rich who's got to help everybody to put
them all aside and look at what is right
for the league as a whole because like
every professional league every business
every industry this isn't a one-year
challenge this is a multi-year challenge
for all of these in specifically
speaking professional leagues and in the
NBA yeah because you know delaying the
start of the next season to December is
what maybe some owners in the league
would like to do or have been pushing to
do for a long time so it might actually
dovetail into a consensus woge and the
fact that again that's what all
commissioners do is they try to they try
to lead via consensus and in
that respect though the even is the
issue of this date of May first and what
it would mean in terms of opening up
facilities and according to your
reporting that was difficult to even
gain a consensus on that to the point
where there was a little bit of a can
kick correct on that front right they
moved they moved the date from May 1st
to May 8th and they had told teams they
told some teams over last weekend will
do it the first and among those teams
who could have opened on the first based
on their state loosening stay at home
regulations the Atlanta Hawks Atlanta
decided we're not ready to do that we
don't feel comfortable doing it we want
to see what happens within our state
with the loosening of the restrictions
we want to see what does it do to cases
in this state does it does it create a
spike do Kate do cases of the virus go
up we want to see what it looks like in
our region our community before we open
back up so we're going to wait a couple
weeks now Atlanta is a team that's not
going to be in the playoffs and there's
a different urgency for the Atlanta
Hawks then say the Lakers who want to
win a championship the Clippers Philly
Milwaukee these are all certainly team
to have a lot of stake would like to
seize the season resume to want to make
a run in the playoffs but but I will say
this rich in talking with teams and
executives and owners safety has been
for most like of course there's the
competitive juices and people want to
win but III think that no one wants to
put people in it there's always going to
be risk and they'll be risk when they
have whenever they return well you
remember it's not just the players
you've got coaches in their late 60s
early 70s around players you have staff
that's older and people who might be
more vulnerable in the environment and
they've got to account for all that and
and again that's part of your article on
espn.com
I've got Adrian will general ski the
senior NBA insider for ESPN also the
host of the loge pod that's got shefter
and Jeff Passan mentioned it yesterday
when he was on the show loads right here
on the Richardson show the
testing the actual testing that would be
required to get this done and the
sensitivity of what we've already heard
I mean when when Rudy Gobert was
announced as kovat positive and we found
out that the entire Utah Jazz had gotten
tested within 24 hours and this is way
before even the current testing scenario
in our country which is still by many
accounts in fact based in science
accounts woefully short in terms of the
amount of Americans there are so and
that's a sensitivity that's being played
out right now with the Commissioner
correct it is and you know I reported
the story that the NBA expects that in a
shortened season in a what would likely
be a isolated bubble whatever you call
it with with with in a world where you'd
have to be testing more than just
players and staff there might be hotel
workers there might be
facility people any number of people who
have to be around to play that they
would need in the neighborhood of 15,000
tests to do that and what Adam Silver
has set the beginning he doesn't want to
be in a situation where the league is
trying to resume or the league resumes
and there is still a great gap between
the need and the general public and
medical professions where there's a big
gap between the testing they need and
the testing they have and that here
comes a professional sports league
that's gobbling up all those tests now
man you there are manufacturers I think
the NBA knows they could get the tests
they could get the number they need but
well they can have that guarantee but
where they can't guarantee is that the
public will have that and I think from I
think it's an ethical question it's a
public relations question it's it's all
of those how's that going to look and so
that as much as anything is driving the
pushing of this calendar as far as they
can until the testing availability to
people and rapid rapid testing rapid
response testing rapid result testing
is available and so that's a big part of
this conversation right now
so where where are the players in this
conversation what what would you say if
we pulled the players how many would say
absolutely I am up for quarantining I am
up for getting tested I am up for doing
whatever is necessary to get this season
going in front of no fans and crowning a
champion
what would you say that would be my
experience my experience my
conversations I'm not talking to 450 or
400 plus of them right but the general
sense I've gotten from talking to
players is most want to play I don't
find the number any different than any
other part of this I took talking trying
to talk to people at all levels I think
there's different levels of optimism
among the players about whether it'll
happen or not but that's like that's not
want to do it that's I hope we can pull
it together I think there's no question
that the teams who are vying to go deep
in the playoffs who want to who think
they have a chance to win they're more
motivated I think that that's natural
but the others there's a financial cost
the league will essentially take back
for every game that's missed you're
going to lose about 1 percent of your
salary so if all the regular season
games got canceled they didn't play
anymore and different teams have a
different amount left it's anywhere from
23 to 26 percent of a player's salary
they're gonna lose and so that's the
motivation now I don't think under any
scenario let's say some teams have 16 17
games left there's no we can just look
at we can do the math we can look at the
dates ago they're not going to be able
to play that many but if they can play 5
6 7 or or less it is some income back
that they would be losing so there's
lots of different reasons for players to
be motivated to do it and that's part of
the conversation now for the league do
we do we even have that we finish any of
the regular season or do we just go
right to the playoffs and that's in the
end I think it's going to come down to
calendar and how many days they think
they have to finish a season well I mean
you can ask Steve Kerr if he thinks he's
gonna fight
regular-season game the rest this year
again he told the University of San
Francisco and who is on a zoom call or
some sort of on Tuesday he's on some
sort of call with uh with a group
they're saying that they're operating as
if the season's over that they're in the
offseason right now that's what he said
about as you pointed out that's a little
bit their mindset but I think also he
understands they may be called back to
play and their III I think I understand
from the teams who are deep in the
lottery and especially now there's some
younger teams rich that's now they have
a balance they asked um younger older
guys there's no I don't think there's a
great motivation to put Steph Curry back
in five or six regular season games off
of a shortened training camp but for
teams like let's say Cleveland Atlanta
whoever younger rosters Charlotte with
some of the younger guys who are either
playoffs they're going to treat it like
a little bit of a summer league a mini
camp and we just want to get our guys
back in the gym we can run practices for
two and a half three we don't really
care so much about the games but we
we've got young players so we want to
get better and we want to bring those
guys back in and I think you know that's
you know that's important too I mean the
number of different agendas or concepts
or reasons for playing or reasons for
not playing that you've just mentioned
was over the last several minutes I mean
my head is spinning so there's so much
obviously placed in front of the
commissioner right now let's just try
and put a button on it because I do want
to ask you a last dance question before
I let you go what what do you think is
that what's the time frame best you can
tell and what do you think is the best
plan from what you're hearing or the
most viable plan from what you're
hearing that's in front of Adam silver
right now that he may pick up off his
desk and say let's try this one
well I still think they're sifting
through the plans I mean the the single
site is a plan you know they've had
teams you know give us let's look at
your practice facilities in a place
where they could do some innovative
television angles in a facility with no
with no fans but you could do some
things with camera try to make it you
know that you know those are the options
for them I think a single place that
houses everybody you know it certainly
makes sense and there's places Vegas
Walt Disney in Florida are two places
they've talked about and so that'll be
that'll be a big part of it okay
then the last one for you here whoa on
the last dance you had Jerry Krause on
your pod before he passed away what do
you make of how Krauss is coming across
in this in this documentary so far and
what we can pretty much sense what might
be coming I know Jason here was on this
show on Monday and said that there will
be some table pounders on behalf of
Krauss that that that sees some light of
day in the stock I'm wondering what you
think I haven't watched the it Ridge you
haven't I haven't watched it so I will
I'm sure at some point but I have heard
the you know I've seen the reporting and
some of the fallout of it and and I did
have Jerry cross on the podcast I went
to his house last six weeks maybe before
he passed away and the podcast it's June
early June 2000 was so it was 1772 he
passed away yes but but but I haven't I
haven't watched it yet so I don't have
the context of how I'm afraid to jump
into sure how he's been not well I mean
look the the thing that is coming across
to me is crowds was only doing what
Reinsdorf kind of hired him to do watch
right I mean so it it's coming across
like he insisted Phil's gotta go or he
couldn't get along and I'm you know
hey that that's basically how it's going
right now yeah I think it's like
anything else rich I think two things
could be true he did an incredible job
putting this team together the parts the
pieces how they fit from coach from
coaching staff to putting text winter
with text winter with Phil Jackson in a
system and then obviously all the moves
around Michael Jordan that were made and
then when Jordan retired he came back he
built a second team around him and on
the back end he was too anxious for it
to end and he was too desirous of credit
and wanting and like both can be true
because these things are always complex
and it's never good versus bad but I
think listen they all needed each other
like none of us would have happened
without all of them and but I understand
you know I think in Krause it was always
hard for him he was always going to be
treated like an outsider on that group
and I think for the organization and
like Phil Jackson the players they like
finding an enemy a villain and in real
time then we know that's what they did
with Jerry Krause they made him that was
the rallying cry was against Jerry
Krause and so I think Jackson and Jordan
found value in that to push the team and
I think in some ways crout's was
collateral damage in that and and I
think I saw the Steve Kerr quote where
he said he said all those things I just
said incredibly deserves incredible
credit but sometimes Jerry couldn't get
out of his own way and I agree with that
too well watch when you do get around to
it it's it's a fascinating watch I'll
tell you that I'm sure it is yeah I'm
looking forward to it and I know I'll
see it down the road okay hey whoa thank
you for the time really appreciate it
you know I know it's it's been a while
but Congrats on everything that you have
built from from your own bare hands man
and I know what a platform it is to be
on ESPN and the listen with you shefter
and passing were terrific talking about
covering I appreciate it
the kind words Rebecca you know how I
feel watch thank you for calling in
we'll chat soon I'm sure you look for my
call look for my call cuz this is a
fluid story to say the least
obviously for sure okay you guys thank
you got it the you two that's Adrian
what you're asking you're on the Rich
Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here